well we've waited months for the
government's heat and building strategy
it's important because homes account for
around 15
of all of the uk's carbon emissions and
the idea is to incentivize people to
move to electricity by making them pay
more for using gas but will this work
and is it fair
who should pay for greening our homes
david to you first
i think we know a few things the first
is that this transition needs to happen
a recent study i saw suggested that
actually twice as much emissions are
coming from home heaters as they're
coming from all of the country's power
emissions we know that the country will
be better off and prices will be cheaper
in the medium and long term if we make
this transition and we know to this
point that the prices that we have been
paying don't reflect the true cost of
burning these fuels i think globally the
imf believes that fossil fuels are being
subsidized to the tune of five or six
trillion
dollars every year um to me the answer
is quite clear that the government's
role is to make sure that things that
look appealing and attractive in the
medium and long term can be afforded
today and i think for that reason
it's the government's role to be sure
now taxes can play a role there but i'd
like to see the uk government also doing
more subsidy on the uptake and on the
electricity end so that it's not just a
stick approach but also a carrot
approach
so who should be paying for it
governments
consumers or industry alice 28 of
homeowners in the uk don't plan to
eco-upgrade their homes at tax
incentives the answer
i mean look i can i can speak from the
perspective of someone through my work
in photography and filmmaking who's been
traveling to climate front lines and i
can completely understand for uk
homeowners this issue might feel distant
abstract coming far down the line but we
really
have an incredible amount of evidence
we've had it for decades and if we
needed any more there have been historic
flooding in germany historic wildfires
across california um
i i would ask what other choice we have
than to lead this transition and and i
would speak of our sort of massive
responsibility to do so and to do so as
quickly as possible um you know the rate
of our we are in the uk the home of the
industrial revolution we began this sort
of hugely
uh
misguided fossil fuel experiment um and
now i really believe that it's our role
to lead the transition out of it is it
going to be easy to retrofit 29 million
homes
absolutely not um but i would say that
the cost of inaction far outweighs
uh the cost of action and and you know
as as david says and and as he painted
so powerfully in his book this is
literally talking about trillions of of
damage if we don't take action and just
briefly david before we move on how does
the u.s compare by comparison america
huge energy consumers but also huge
potential for renewables
well we're not doing nearly as well as
the uk uh we have a much smaller share
of renewable power um but we're on the
brink i hope of making massive
investments here to green our grid um
with the with the infrastructure
reconciliation bills that are being
talked about right now so we i would say
we're lagging behind but i i hope that
if we were talking a month from now the
picture would look a lot greener